The Do's Of Assisting With Panic Attacks
A panic attack is a sudden urge of overwhelming anxiety and fear
That can occur anywhere at any time
If ever observing someone experiencing an attack
Do not panic, the person suffering
the panic attack does not need the extra stress of
someone else panicking and screaming at them. Instead there are some
Helpful ways to assist someone through a panic attack.
If it is the first time the individual is experiencing this
Seek medical attention.
Having a panic attack
Can be overwhelming enough, but experiencing it for the first time
Makes it even more stressful.
Especially if the individual doesn't know what's going on.
Although a panic attack is non life threatening on it's own
It's best to call for emergency medical attention if in doubt.
This is especially important if the person has asthma,
diabetes or other medical conditions.
Ensure the individual experiencing the attack is breathing
If the individual is standing or leaning
against an object, it's best that they sit down.
This will make breathing easier and insure minimal harm if they faint.
The person may remain unresponsive or hyperventilate too quickly
And fall unconscious. If this is the case,
Lay them down, listen to their breathing, and check their pulse.
check their pulse. The average adult heart beats 60 times per minute
The average adult heart beats 60 time per minute so try to keep track of the clock
As you take their pulse. If their hyperventilating
or breathing too quickly, ask the individual to take
a breath with every other number you say and begin counting to 10.
counting to 10
start counting at a slightly sped up pace
but as their rate of breathing falls decrease their speed of counting
until the individual is breathing at a regular pace.
If their not breathing at all, calmly ask them
to attempt to take a single breath.
This request may have to be repeated several times, and once they respond
continue to make this request.
The goal is to have the person breathing on their own.
Ask grounding questions.
This is a frightening time for the individual
experiencing the attack, and confusion can often come with the panic
Asking simple questions can help ground them.
Grounding questions require that the individual answers without having to over think.
For example; What is your name?
Where are you from? and what is your favorite color?
These questions provide an anchor
that the individual can focus on. If the individual is unable to provide
verbal answers, then ask yes or no questions.
These still require that the individual focus on the answer
and be sure to give them time to answer each question
and do not overwhelm them or pressure them into answering quickly.
Patience is extremely important here
Ask if the individual is okay with being touched
In a yes or no form.
If the answer is yes, slowly move toward the individual
while remaining in their immediate range of eyesight
Once close enough, you may calmly lay a hand
On theirs. anymore contact
should only be initiated from the individual having the attack.
If the individual requests not to be touched,
Then simply continue to ask grounding questions.
You can also repeat where the individual is. (Work, school etc)
and that they are safe.
Do not ever touch a person who is experiencing a panic attack
without asking or receiving permission to do so.
In some cases, the situation can get worse and their panic can increase
if the individual is touched without permission.
Do not leave the individual struggling through the panic attack alone
One of the scariest parts of a panic attack
is the inability to focus on all parts of reality
The individual knowing that they are not alone
they are not alone can make resurfacing from the panic attack easier.
the panic attack easier. Do you have any tips on helping someone through a panic attack?
Let us know in the comments below!
If you like this video, be sure to check out our other social media for more content.
for more content. and don't forget to subscribe!
Thanks for watching!